on retrouve tout de suite gulliver craag
notre correspondant sur place à kiev
gulliver bonsoir les ukrainiens auraient
donc repris ir pin
c'est ce que dit le maire dira pin en
tout cas il dit que la ville a été
totalement libérée mais je pense que
c'est encore une information à prendre
un petit peu avec des pincettes en tout
cas on est encore assez loin du moment
où les 60000 habitants évacués dire pin
seront habités à revenir sur site
l'accès sera très limité pour le moment
puisque les ukrainiens disent devoir
continuer à mener des opérations de
nettoyage et d'ailleurs c'est ce qui y
est planifiée pour demain nettoyage ça
veut dire aussi éradication de russes
qui resteraient sur place donc je pense
que on ne peut pas dire que la ville a
été totalement
vidé deux russes deux soldats de combat
ton russe si vous voulez mais en tout
cas il faut croire que c'est un pas en
avant pour les ukrainiens dont leur
contre attaque dans les banlieues au
nord ouest fief réguler hiver il est de
plus en plus question sur place de
crimes de guerre côté russe racontez
nous
oui aujourd'hui j'ai assisté à une
conférence de presse de la procureur
général d'ukraine et les navets l'édito
va qui dit que le crâne a déjà ouvert
des cas pour toute une série de sortes
de crimes de guerre que ce soit le
bombardement de zones civiles
que ce soit la tuerie habitants de
villages et de villes qui ont été tout
simplement fusillés par des russes sur
place pour certains de ces cas il existe
des vidéos et des photos en plus des
témoignages d'autres habitants il y a
aussi des crimes sexuels irina benedicto
va a dit qu'un prisonnier de guerre
russe est en fait déjà enquêté il sera
jugé pour crimes sexuels il est accusé
elle dit qu il y a beaucoup beaucoup
plus d'accusation en ce sens elle a
aussi dit que le cren évalue la
possibilité aussi d'accuser la russie
d'un crime contre l'humanité qui serait
le génocide des habitants de marioupol
je pense que l'utilisation de ce terme
est très controversé c'est sûr qu'il ya
eu un massacre à marioupol que les
civils ont été ciblés indiscriminée mans
mais de là à dire que le but était
effectivement d'éliminer et anéantir
tous les habitants de marioupol je ne
sais pas si les ukrainiens vont vraiment
pouvoir retrouver de telles intentions
mais il est important je pense dessous
de souligner que c'est un terme qui
circule très largement chez les
ukrainiens beaucoup beaucoup de gens
parlent de cette idée de génocide non
pas seulement contre les habitants de
marioupol m'est intention génocidaire
contre les ukrainiens de la part de la
russie de vladimir poutine s'est
vraiment dans les esprits en ce moment
merci beaucoup gulliver et on vous
retrouvera 19h10 dans le débat sur
france 24 sur cette question ukrainienne